je voudrais vous parler parce que vous
savez conduire une famille aussi était
pleine paix et je suis très triste ce
soir car il ya un personnage très
important qui va quitter tpm poli qui va
quitter donc des pmp qui va quitter
l'aventuré
c'est notre chef de plateau c'est david
baudon david c'est lui regardez magnéto
c'est parti
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
alors c'est quoi
voilà david c'était un petit apparition
dans tpm paix et david bono cayla bon
david damour ces sondes étaient pmp
softs qui va repartir vers une nouvelle
aventure vient mon ami gabon suit
réglages face au doyen mon chéri adore
applaudi choix pour la vie merci andré
fabre sûr évident c'est que vraiment le
coeur y est david qui a fait et pmp avec
moi depuis le début sur ces vies c'est
un garçon exceptionnel que j'aime
énormément et david je voulais te dire
qui tu es tu allé beaucoup mourront
d'avis manque énormément toussaint vous
allez me faire chialer là mais je te
jure tu vas vraiment manqué et quand tu
me l'annoncer bas je peux te dire je te
jure que ça m'a vraiment tu vois c'est
j'ai pensé toute la nuit
ouais alors dis nous ce que tu vas faire
parce que c'est vous et bryce dallas lui
s'il est ce qu'il est et dans le monde
du showbiz laquelle doit faire
maintenant
eh ben je vais partir en formation sur
la rochelle je vais faire une formation
de dans la marine de plaisance je change
carrément de métier devient je vais
aller fabriquer entretenir des bateaux
là bas entretenir des bateaux là bas
voilà david r je pars avec femme et
enfants s'ils avaient magnifiquement
tiré alors on david tu sais que je
t'aime très fort et je voulais offrir un
séjour en europe pour deux personnes à
rejoindre à partir où tu veux voilà ça
c'est pour ta femme et toi voilà qui
fait un peu et je voudrais offrir un
petit truc parce que je sais que tu
kiffes voilà la mobilité urbaine et je
vais t'offrir un petit vélo électrique
gentil comme ça tu penseras mois quand
ils déplacera tout à faut la poursuivre
voilà je t'ai offert un ticket
alors il électrique c'est le même connu
et c'est le mal que de bien et son chéri
donc on pourra faire une course tu veux
david je te le dis tu va énormément me
manquer a été exceptionnel pendant
toutes ces années il fait un travail dur
avec ses petits pas sympa et je dois
dire et je pense que tous les
techniciens qui sont là qui travaillent
et david peuvent l'applaudir ce soir
[Applaudissements]
david tu vas nous manquer mon chéri et
enfin petits pots de fleurs du pot de
l'amitié
pendant que je serai doha prendre ou à
laisser allez on lève le masque attraper
les bonbons lès meaux david tu sais que
tu vas me manquer et juste vous dire un
truc sache que si un jour tu changes
d'avis avec tu en as marre corvéables à
merci vous passez directement par mois
ouais d'accord mais aussi en téléphonant
à partir avec plaisir je t'embrasse fort
merci beaucoup merci à david
exceptionnel
il adore ben laden